okay well you touched on it just for a
second you said the word which is
something that i just love so much
and
if there's anything bad about it i'm
just gonna have to chalk it up like i'm
willing to do
really about anything except for in this
one specific area to be more healthy to
have more longevity to
optimize my hormones optimize
energy
but when it comes to coffee i gotta have
coffee
um i went without coffee last year for
about two and a half months i just
stopped and i had no problem i didn't
have a single headache from it i wasn't
less energetic i just love coffee and so
tell me the the good and the bad and
what is sort of like the optimal way to
consume it and i'm sure i'm gonna have
more questions about it but let's just
start there
yeah you know i don't think coffee is as
bad as some people present it to be um
the coffee that i think it's really the
timing of the coffee consumption so for
example um we're recording this at at
one o'clock pacific standard time i
would definitely not advise you have
coffee after this point in the day um
now if you're gonna go do a hard workout
if you're like oh my gosh i haven't seen
my girlfriends in like three months
we're gonna go out tonight find a little
caffeine but caffeine really is
problematic for um helping you fall
asleep it it you know disturbs um all
the adenosine metabolism in the brain so
it's going to augment sleep and so
that's not good but i'm a fan especially
you know we were talking before we
started recording about maybe a
wedding's coming up losing a little
weight you know a lot of people have you
know these want to get in shape for
summer using caffeine before you
exercise has been shown to prevent the
catabolism or the breakdown of muscle
which is a good thing and enhance the
oxidation of fat so
in the morning i'm a big fan of that and
that's i do
a double espresso and
when when choosing the beans i'm a
bigger fan of an organic light roast
and there's a few different reasons for
that but that's what i preferentially
choose
um i periodically will have just say usp
caffeine in the form of like a
pre-workout but i try to use that
sparingly that's sort of like oh my gosh
you know i'm doing something extra
intense today or something's going on
where i need a little bit i really
advise people not be dependent upon
pre-workouts and straight up caffeine
and use use coffee
as a little a little tool but where
people get into problems with coffee is
they have the coffee then they have the
the stevia packets or they have splenda
where they have a bunch of sugar um and
it becomes basically a four or five six
hundred calorie energy bomb which
that can add up you know you add in
three meals there plus some wine plus
some beer you're looking at three to
four thousand calories and unless you're
really active you're probably going to
gain some weight so those are my
thoughts on coffee well i drink it black
total purist
um so you talked about the timing and
this is because i've read a lot and
watched a lot of videos about coffee and
timing and sunlight and you know
that there that your body um has sort of
the natural energy
from
waking up and is that cortisol that
produces that and kind of gives you a
burst and that it really you should wait
at least an hour perhaps after you wake
up to drink it
me i i wake up i force myself to drink a
glass of water
and i actually put right now i put um
some aloe vera water aloe vera in it and
then um i put a little bit of lemon
juice
and some apple cider vinegar just just a
little bit and so i force myself i drink
that or just regular water
but then i'm ready for coffee
and that might only be like 30 40
minutes after i wake up maybe
you know i think that's fine i know a
lot of people do split hairs on having
to wait this amount of time in this
you know some days that's not practical
i mean if you're going off to travel or
you're doing something um but if it
makes my my thing is like if it makes
you feel good and it's you know there's
not a lot of downside so you're like
okay if you only wait 45 minutes what's
the worst that's going to happen your
cortisol awakening in response which is
theoretically why people are saying
delay the onset of coffee should already
be kicking in even before you wake up
that should be sort of waking me wait
awakening you so i don't worry about
that there's other things that i worry
about i would you know and if we're too
regimented this is another thing if
we're if we exert too much willpower i'm
only going to consume this much coffee
i'm going to meditate i got to exercise
i can't have sugar i can't do this then
by the time it's 10 o'clock you're like
oh my gosh forget it i need that glass
of wine or i need some ice cream so we
need to be mindful about how much
willpower
and how much restraint we're sort of
inserting into our day
and so i think you know having a little
coffee not a big deal if it's within a
half an hour 40 minutes awakening sure
sure
um this is a little bit of a side
question to the coffee but sort of in in
light of getting sunlight in the morning
i have a big you know juve like six
panel red light and um
and i think i kind of know the answer
but i'm curious from a scientific
standpoint
sometimes i think to myself oh man
especially right now in arizona it's
like sunny at 5 00 a.m
it's getting sunny and i know that
because that's when i wake up because i
wake up with the light
and i think well should i do the red
light because normally my routine would
be to get up have that water a little
bit of coffee red light stretch a little
bit of yoga during that dry brush cold
shower get some clothes on go walk the
dogs that's kind of my normal routine
but i'm like man
i probably should just skip the red
light and just get outside like it's
it's like
is that accurate or is there some
benefit with red light specifically is
there
more um density of those wavelengths
that it's giving you that helps with the
mitochondria and other kinds of things
that it's meant to improve or should you
just get outside
it's a great question i think this time
of year you should just get outside yeah
um especially for you it's starting to
get warmer and warmer and then you may
not be outside in the middle part of the
day so i think that's more important um
there are definitely some mitochondrial
benefits with regards to and i we too
have the six panel juve and it's an
awesome setup right um but i i consider
that more therapeutic in the winter time
specifically you mentioned how the heck
do you survive in seattle like that is
because sometimes it doesn't get light
out until 8 30 you know um like
and that's really tough so that's where
i think the juve comes in and also it
can help with an injury let's say for
example you're like well i have a bicep
injury or
you know was training had some
challenges um
i know you recently got into a a an
accident right there was a spinning
situation going on so maybe that could
help with the recovery then you go
outside but but i think if you're gonna
you know
i would definitely prefer the sun over
the juve as much as i love the juve
i have a lot of questions about fasting
but first i want to start off with just
being a fat burner versus a sugar burner
and
i get that you know once you become more
metabolically flexible you should be
able to kind of tap into either and then
perhaps you're not as hungry as often
because your body is adapted and it can
shift sort of
energy mechanisms but how the hell do
you know if you're burning fat or sugar
because i get hungry and i try and i
mean i try to minimum 12 hours um and
then sometimes you know a little bit
more depending on the situation or the
um the time of the month but um but how
do we know when we're burning fat versus
sugar
the really practical way to do this is
actually to test and you can get a
glucometer and i encourage all my
clients to do this is just go down to
walgreens or rite aid or your closest
drug store
people think oh a glucose meter that's
only for diabetics no this is for
everyone we need to know
how our body is processing the foods
that we eat and we need to know how our
lifestyle is impacting the post meal
processing so
you mentioned like even if you eat a low
carb diet
for example but most people in the post
meal window their blood sugar is going
to go up so you're naturally going to
sort of
oxidize or burn more glucose in the post
meal window but most americans
unfortunately stay in that state because
not only are they eating foods that
dramatically increase the glucose but
they're snacking every two to three
hours or more and so the glucose is
they're always sort of oxidizing or
burning glucose and never get to the
point to where
maybe your eye would be in because we
exercise and because we compress that
feeding window aka we fast we get to the
point where the glucose goes down
and the body needs energy and it starts
to dip into the fat stores and we can
talk about hormonally why that happens
but to specifically again address the
question how do you know you would get a
glucose meter you would start to test
your glucose and about you could do like
30 minutes after it's just a little
finger prick 29 gauge it stings a little
bit but it's no big deal so you could
test your glucose again 30 minutes after
a meal
60 minutes after the meal in 90 minutes
and you should see that glucose starting
to come down and that would indicate
that as glucose comes down then you
start your you should start to oxidize
fats for fuel uh in the post meal window
[Music]